ciao ragazzi è tornato in una puntata di
cucina buttata a summer edition oggi
faremo un crono gigante e per gigante
intendo gigante un cono gelato più o
meno un peso di due etti il nostro credo
che avrà più o meno un peso di cinque
chili come se anche sei tu sei pazzo sì
e ne sono fiero dunque thing per fare la
crema del nostro cono avremo bisogno di
4 litri di latte intero un litro 750 ton
fresca 920 grammi di zucchero e 4
baccelli di vaniglia praga un baccello
di vaniglia con te che costa tipo 51
quasi 5 euro non siamo matti noi ne
abbiamo preso quattro per fare la torta
del nostro collo avremo bisogno di altri
320 grammi di zucchero qualora non fosse
abbastanza del quasi kg di prima a 120 g
di albumi 320 grammi di farina 00 e 320
grammi di burro per le decorazioni
invece avremo bisogno di 200 grammi di
cioccolato fondente nocciole intere e
altro cioccolato fondente che ci
avanzava quindi perché buttarlo e
procedimenti 4 litri di latte mamma mia
versiamo a questo punto lo zucchero
bellissimo
prendiamo una ri minatore ma chi è quel
ma perché ci sta faccia la linea era
viene annunciata in poi quindi un po
media anche una chiusura è tipo quando
vai al mare sotto c'è la sabbia questo
qui doveva metterlo sulla fiamma breve
per prima di semini dell'america dentro
come aprire un baccello di vaniglia ve
lo faccio vedere subito incidere nella
lunghezza il baccello e lo divido in due
in modo che poi ti ritrovi una vita
dell'altra da poter accarezzare con la
parte non affidata del coltello
ecco adesso proseguiamo per tutti gli
anti tre gioielli
una della reggina ma è un disastro
alla prossima puntata è pronto mi
prendete in giro per fare il gelato ci
sono due modi o freddo o al caldo se
lamenta caldo si usa per le ricettazioni
con l'uovo anche questo si potrebbe fare
a caldo ma non ci abbiamo tempo perché
questi sei chili di liquido dovremmo
passare in una gelatina grossa così
frulliamo tutto e non firmate in
superficie
adesso aggiungiamo la panna
direttamente dentro la mente si frulla
dio benedica i regali pensavo fossero
inutili questa cosa genera in me sarah
l'ha regalata per i 28 anni mai
utilizzata è arrivato il momento di
battezzarla prendiamo dell'alcol
[Musica]
effettivamente l'alcol permette al
freddo di passare velocemente e più
facilmente più agevolmente al cestello
senza contare che rende ancora più
facile quando poi estrae perché
essendoci un liquido che non congela che
si è posto
hai messo tanto alcol pochi parini come
sempre
perciò praticamente ragazzi per fare
sull eternità e ti portano è ancora al
tema con sé a fare i turni non so quanto
tecnico motivo per cui abbiamo attaccato
alle 8 di mattina perché così almeno ci
sarà ancora il sole e vuole quando vede
remo si spera passiamo a vedere che cosa
c'è fuori adesso il buio via 7 una
svampa di altro ma sei sicuro di quello
che stai facendo tu di edificio il mio
ti picchio inseriamo questo caso come si
chiama ragazzi questo è mica ventola
mescolatore girella inseriamo la
sbruffona ea questo punto riempiamo il
cestello il quanto possiamo desiderare
azione sacchetta più questa ci salverà
qualcuno deve fare questo processo sei
volte almeno gianni e prime così un
bellissimo sarà partiamo intanto
facciamo mezz'ora 30 minuti per 10 volte
non basta un umanità per fare questo
gelato ragazzi non sono i 16 30 minuti è
giusto
mi è venuta un'idea geniale nel
frattempo mettiamo tutto il boccaloni in
freezer in modo che mentre quello sì
falli questo qui in comincia pian piano
a ghiacciarsi sono un genio e ogni tanto
vengo qui gli dona girata in modo che
quando lo buttiamo lì è ancora più
veloce il tempo il tuo cugino
allora ancora che andare io sono un fan
del coordinatore che dividono la
nocciola ai ricorrenti gusto del gelato
preferito traccia della stagione
davico lento gusto di gelato preferito
caffè un monito pure questo questo
preferito ma devo sapere commenti così
posso arrabbiarmi occhi ho visto
lanciato da io mi sto viaggiando le mani
sono distrutta come oddio sono troppo
esaltato a vela giorno non vi contendono
di questo perfetta perché questa è una
riscatto e anche di mito è una meta che
bello quando non c'era che queste cose è
piacevolissimo dell'area stupendo mi a
chi te che hai una io so che state
facendo delle cose non consone vecchia
cosa non c'è problema affondarci 5 kg di
creato senza di te infatti la hanno
fatto schifezze sera deve assaggiare no
comunque un'epopea questa ricetta
gianmarco shaka la casacca rossonera che
marca la calma chiudiamo anziano questo
lo spettro in freezer
non ce la fai te lo prometto
ma gianmarco
ti stai facendo niente
niente una radio che cosa si sta
sgonfiando stavo per soffiare che e
mezzo sconfino avrà un punto pare è
comunque non è solo un contabile
[Applauso]
mentre facciamo andare avanti gelato ho
pensato una cosa geniale ci guarda
avanti con la cialda conseguente alla
fine la ciarda tutto riempì tanto da un
anno e mezzo è sotto l'ombelico tiene
vediamo gli albumi li mettiamo dentro
ciotola zucchero a velo
ringraziamo my personal trainer per
questa ricetta è a questo punto la
vogliamo velocemente albumi e zucchero
abbiamo trovato un reperto storico e
cosa del pane video santo mamma mia
mamma tua si sono gabriele per francesco
la linea e mia madre via bionda con un
cappello da grande
a questo punto chiedete la vostra
assistente di sciogliere tutto questo
burro al microonde braganza è che
bersani possa in qualche modo inizierà
cuocere il tuorlo enrico di ho visto
pochino e poi la farina
in realtà esiste un altro modo da non
fare vi mostro questo metodo
se aggiungiamo poco liquido a tanta
farina automaticamente di milioni
a me viene solo un termine in mente
anarchico l'attrito che si crea tra le
varie particelle di farina e scompone
tutte quante quando invece poteva venire
interno il liquido maggiore ci creano i
nomi perché per che naviga e quindi si
sa se uscirà quando me lo sto dicendo no
non parlavo con noi che hanno valore che
elezioni sono quelle che ricevono questo
grazie ma dov'è il posto l'ha preso
enrico errico amico cosa farò ma piena
di doni del creato che l'aspettiamo con
dentro non saprò
come pensa la bacchetta primo da forno
preriscaldato a 200 gradi la teniamo
dentro cinque seduti o mio dio la
bellezza
praticamente una lingua di gatto gigante
e genera liguri con volumi così sembrava
godere vivono anche così sembra monito
sì ma stai calmo ecco ci aspettiamo
allora preghiamo dio poi ti prego
oddio la guarda
c'è troppo buio ma personal trainer
diceva ai volumi vediamo in grumi
guardate cosa c'è in forno un incubo
meno male core citato stavano bene
perché con qualcosa in forma non mi ci
fai pensare ma un bambino è uno stress
pazzesco a uno stress pazzesco in un
suggerimento per fare una forma con i
tale così grande è quello di prenderlo
strumento che abbiamo tutti quanti nelle
nostre cucine che è un comodissimo
comoda strada bike è destinato ad andare
tutto male mi aveva di ustioni alle mani
di tenaris targati masculina senza
pensarci paroli raga io vi giuro di da
una lira senti valutazioni a caldo
piangere pazzesco liga ripetiamo il
procedimento una terza volta avevamo
messo il cono in forno per farlo seccare
un po diciamo niente accoglie riesco io
scattiamo in voi quanto tornassero
falloni pati mite che la rogna più
grande da essere questo in ogni dieci
chili dice la leopard
[Musica]
che succede un problema no mannaggia
devo operare in ferma non anche se lo
lascia aperto questa ricetta mi portava
gialli che accogliamo considera è legata
in questa poesia sono passate sente ore
16 giorni e due mesi da quando abbiamo
iniziato questo video
volevo chiedere sociale di josh e anzi a
marco non sorride più la linea
la finanza proprio che fiamme fatto lo
sentite di sottofondo il rumore della
gelatiera che continua a cenare dare
tutto per un cono gelato gigante
copiarci ce la possiamo fare ad arrivare
alla fine di tutto questa è la care alla
fine mettete un like una mano sul cuore
e ricordatevi di noi possiamo far vedere
che cosa c'è fuori adesso il buio
volturi ecco alimenta gioie che la
vittima felicità che vivrete in piazza
google se va bene tutto ma azioni
insensate no è bucato sotto ho un'idea
li mettiamo del cioccolato fondente che
facciamo scendere giù se il cioccolato
andrà a tapparlo quindi sarà mediamente
facciamo il cappello dall'altre ieri
notte o due giorni di cui questa è la
soddisfazione ragazzi con questo i
prezzi questo se lo censurano per quanto
è porno
sono troppo col dente farmaci qatar è
storicamente la mamma mia interessante
iniziamo a limpido riempire il cono
anche delicatezza tolta la cornucopia
per aspettare che giocato si raffreddi
perché se non lo apriamo e mi pare che
ci sia riuscito questo è stato fatto sei
uno scienziato pazzo manier mi fa così
paura così vuoi scherzare
vuoi sposarmi nocciole intere
giustamente il certo le perdiamo g
la cosa più bella che abbia mai visto se
un uomo mi porta una cosa del genere lo
sposo è messo troppo poco dell'auto la
testa mette a si aspettino di mettere
tre mittente è stato un parto per cui vi
presento mio figlio madonna ha una
consistenza terribile affetto adesso
poverino questo kebab è malridotto ma
avendolo visto io prima abbracciato al
suo bambino ho trovate una cosa più
bella che io non bellissimo ma nel suo
insieme falso porca figura 8 è bello non
si può dire niente sette e mezzo è una
vera impresa brown
adesso gli dà un 3 ma appena uscita era
un 9 benissimo
vabbè autori non ce l'ha mi sento
cioccolato non mi dice niente asettico
miti bideau non classificato odore 6 nel
senso una cosa che affamano l'autore o 5
mi sto portando comunque trovare
finalmente come si faccia questo coso
ghiaccio al cervello questi sono i me
[Musica]
penso di essermi sbrodolato almeno fino
al ginocchio destro che ha accavallato
sotto al sinistro ma il bello della
diretta sapore è stato tosta la quale
non è male che gli do 7 quanto magari
prima cosa i ragazzi è una torta una
torta gelato da 7 kg quindi sui 45 euro
ma questa un valore aggiunto non meno di
40 euro cosa del genere per tutta la
roba che c'è dentro qui il lavoro che ci
vuole per farlo mesi 40 euro
è buonissima se consideriamo tutto il
lavoro 23 mila abbiamo risolto io questo
non lo tocco la terra rossa gil nulla
non toccato dai aspetto non l'ho
assaggerò mai se volete vi do un voto
sull'odore aspetto per pagare per questo
piatto ragazzi siamo arrivati a piedi
questo video è stato un parto
plurigemellare ma ne basta per vivere
come tende c'è un like fateci sapere
come state passata vostra vacanza cosa
state facendo se siete partiti siano
ancora non siete partiti
insomma teneteci aggiornati su quello
che è il vostro agosto noi continueremo
a farlo questo youtube ma allo stesso
tempo su instagram mediare un pochino
più immediata io li mando un bacio
grande ci vediamo giovedì con un altro
video della summer edition
ciao
[Risate]